avengers end game is probably one of my
favorite comic book movies of all time
it's packed from top to bottom with
references to other films in the
infinity saga
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down 200 of the best easter
eggs in it
as always welcome to the heavy spoiler
show i'm your host paul aka your
friendly neighborhood spoiler man
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
endgame opens with hawkeye teaching his
daughter how to fire arrows
not only is this actually joe russo's
daughter ava
but we can also catch a glimpse of the
tracking device that was placed on
clint's ankle after the events of civil
war
this ankle monitor would of course pop
up in ant-man and the wasp
with scott lang two being forced to wear
one after breaking the sokovia records
the bullseye that we see actually
appeared in age of ultron
in clint's barn just before tony came
face to face with nick fury
we can hear birds in the background
chirping away but after the snap is
carried out
these suddenly disappear after this snap
is reversed we get a scene of ant-man
coming across some birds on a tree
showing that things have returned to
normal in the bible
birds are very symbolic and noah of
course used several to determine whether
the earth had returned back to normal
similar to what we see in these moments
you can catch the faintest glimmer of
dust blowing in the wind
which of course symbolizes that
hawkeye's family have been killed
dust is also symbolic of the bible as
the phrase ashes to ashes and dust to
dust
is used to describe death half of all
life in the universe has been wiped out
and this too is later hinted at by the
title scene in which the avengers theme
is actually played by half the orchestra
this was purposely done by alan
silvestri in order to emphasize the way
that the world was
speaking of title sequences when the
marvel studios logo comes in
all of the characters that were dusted
don't actually appear in it at all
we can see in the one for infinity war
and the one for endgame
that a lot of the characters are missing
which hammers home that they have been
completely erased from existence
speaking of infinity war there's
actually several details set up in the
film
which pay off directly in this one when
talking to dr strange tony stark and
wong
bruce banner is surprised to learn that
ben and jerry's have named an ice cream
flavor after him
this gets a big follow-up in endgame
when we see hulk eating it during the
planning stages of the time heist
in infinity war tony used a nanotech
shield to cover himself from an attack
by thanos and this severely depleted his
supply of the microscopic machines
and led to him almost being killed in
order to make sure this doesn't happen
again
in end game stock instead uses an energy
shield as protection
which won't drain on his armor kurta
tony playing paper football with nebula
and he flicks it with amazing accuracy
probably because
they've had not much else to do out in
space it's a bit bit like lockdown i
suppose
now tony later does this with ant-man
when he flicks him across the room at
avengers tower
we can also hear the song dear mr
fantasy which contains the line
make it snappy is is that a reach
probably anyway this scene is
full of fun little nods in easter eggs
and we can catch tony at one point
wearing his black tank top
as he and nebula try and find a way to
fix the ship not only is this
referencing the cave scene in iron man 1
in which he and yinsen built the ark
reactor in suit
but it's also something that's appeared
throughout the saga in iron man 2
and tony is trying to create a new
element he dones it there
and he also puts it on in iron man 3
when he's sleeping and suffers from a
ptsd dream
typically this is worn when tony is in a
vulnerable position
and he has to use his smarts to deal
with the situation
the cockpit of the ship also resembles
iron man's helmet
and i love the composition of this shot
which shows both aspects of tony's
personality
he records a message for peppa and tells
her not to post it on social media
which is a reference to the star of iron
man when the character took a picture
with a soldier
and told him not to post it online tony
also recorded a message for peppa and
nine man 3
which was played back when she put on a
helmet so this is a nice little
continuation of that theme
tony says it's you
it's always been you when the character
made her ceo this idea of recording a
final message into the helmet is of
course brought back up at the end of the
movie
when tony leaves one to his family at
the character's funeral
this shot of the helmet on the table
echoes tony putting the mark 1 helmet on
one during the cave scene in iron man 1
so we get this idea of things coming
full circle with the first and last
appearance of the iron man helmet
being set up exactly the same way tony
also dies whilst carrying out the snap
with the focus of the scene being
brought towards his hand
this too mirrors how he was first
introduced all the way back in iron man
1
as in that the very first shot we get of
him is the character holding a whiskey
glass
symbolically we get the idea that tony
has gone from this self-centered
morally bankrupt weapons manufacturer to
someone who is willing to sacrifice
his own life so that others can have
theirs infinity war was all about making
sacrifices in order to win
and this was echoed in several of the
characters doctor strange saved tony in
exchange for the time stone
and loki saved his brother in exchange
for the tesseract
cap famously said that they don't trade
lives when vision offered up his in
order to destroy the mind stone
and it showed that the avengers wouldn't
make the hard play
thus thanos was able to collect all of
the infinity stones in win
and this is because he was willing to
sacrifice gamora
however the avengers win an end game
because they do make sacrifices
which include the death of black widow
and of course tony stark
dramatically it's amazing and it really
pays off what was set up in the prior
film
now the pair are saved by captain marvel
and they return to earth where we see
cap shaving off the glorious beer that
he had in infinity war
pepper and tony hug and this shot is
later mirrored when the pair hug once
more as the latter dies
now peppa leaning in and kissing tony
two mirrors the bath scene in civil war
in which tony's mother said goodbye so
we have this repetition of tony's wife
and his mother
saying farewell in the exact same way
tony and cap have an argument
which also calls back to several moments
from avengers age of ultron
firstly tony mentions a suit of armor
around the world
which is the reason why he created the
mad machine and he also says that he
told them they'd lose
and cap said that they'd do that
together now from here the avengers
travel into space
and we get a close-up shot of captain
america's eye this actually mirrors a
close-up of tony's eye in the avengers
when he too traveled into space for the
first time
cap looks at a photograph of peggy
carter and the character did the same
thing at the end of the first avenger
when he was about to crash the ship at
the end upon arriving on the planet we
see thanos
armor being used as a scarecrow and this
is actually a call back to the comics in
which the character
two did something similar the avengers
bum rush him
and you may notice that one of the
hulkbuster's arms hasn't been painted
this is because that one is actually a
replacement
as the original was used to kill cull
obsidian in infinity war
nebula says that her father isn't a liar
and we've seen throughout his
appearances that he always keeps his
word
he also says to gamora that he never
told her to lie
which is why she's so bad at it but the
character likely did this on purpose so
that his children couldn't betray him
though finally goes for the head which
is of course a call back to the prior
movie
but this idea of beheading thanos goes
far beyond that
in the final battle every time thor
attacks the villain
he goes for the head this was of course
up in avengers infinity war
when due to his need to gloat he went
for the chest
rather than the instant killing blow
because of this thanos was able
to wipe out half of all life in the
universe and retreat to the garden
now during the final fight we watch the
awesome moment in which captain america
lifts ammonia and gains the power of
thor
this helps him to go toe-to-toe with
thanos on a level playing field
and as danos can not lift the item
himself he instead grabs cap's wrist
rather than the hammer now i brought
this up in a prior video
and did get some people saying that this
is untrue as thanos is able to lift
stormbreaker
however they do work in different ways
if you cast your mind back to thor
odin put his spell on the hammer so that
only he who was worthy could lift it
whereas he never put it on stormbreaker
and as the handle is made from grutsom
thanos is able to wield it when using on
thor
he then pushes it into his chest this
actually mirrors how thor drove the axe
into his chest at the end of infinity
war
and we get this nice little parallel of
the two trying to kill each other in the
same way you might also notice that
cap's arm has scales on it
and you can actually see these under the
upper layer of his outfit in the prior
movie
these scales first made an appearance in
black panther
and could show that after dropping off
bucky and wakanda
shuri gave him some upgrades thanos also
breaks cap shield
similar to the way that it was destroyed
in tony stark's vision all the way back
in age of ultron
cut to five years later and we see that
the earth is in complete ruins
now whilst thanos thought he was doing
good by wiping out half of all life
we can see that this really isn't the
case half of the infrastructure of the
planet has been destroyed at random
and thus chaos has caused things to
collapse on a grand scale
steve holds his survivors meeting and we
see joe russo as well as jim stalin who
created thanos in the comics
steve goes to natasha and we can
actually see ballet slippers sitting on
a chair beside her
and this is a call back to age of ultron
in which we learned that she was trained
in ballet
when natasha tells steve that she has to
work on fixing everything
the soundtrack is also a variation on
the soul stone sacrifice music
which foreshadows her death later steve
mentions that there are whales in the
hudson
and okoye 2 talks about an underwater
earthquake
though we don't know what marvel are
going to do with black panther 2
since the passing of chadwick boseman it
has been rumored that the submariner
neymar will be popping up in the film
and this definitely could be a setup
here now if you haven't subscribed to
the channel yet then this is the perfect
time to do it
as we make videos like this each and
every day that you'll definitely love
three thousand
as mentioned earlier my name's paul if
you ever want to come talk to me about
movies tv shows or just things in
general
then you can hit me up on my twitter at
heavyspoilers
anyway curtis scott lang being saved by
a rat and the number on the lockup is
616 which
is a reference to the main marvel
universe earth which carries this
designation
we can catch community alumni ken jong
who is guarding the lockup
and he's reading the book terminal
breach which features a short story in
it called endgame
he's not the only community actor that
pops up either as yvette nicole brown
gets in a lift with tony and steve
when they travel back to the 70s from
here scott travels to a memorial
and we can spot a name for roberto de
costa who you may know as sunspot
sunspot was in the new mutants and just
like how he was killed in the mcu
he also helped to kill that franchise
i'm just kidding
it's fine it's fine so much worse anyway
natasha makes a peanut butter jelly
sandwich which scott then shows up and
eats she cuts it diagonally which is a
call back to nick fury
telling carol that he can't eat toast
that's been cut diagonally
could she be in the habit of doing this
to stop nick from stealing her lunch at
work
we'd like to think so at the channel
anyway the group will team up
and they decide to go to tony for help
tony now lives out in the real world
countryside
and there are several things here that
actually call back to the earlier movies
if you cast your mind back to the ending
of age of ultron tony actually says that
he might retire in bell pepper a farm
his daughter morgan was of course
referenced in infinity war
and we see her wearing the rescue suit
helmet this is a special anniversary
gift for peppa
and the colour has been purposely chosen
as it's the same as the dress that peppa
wore and iron man won
when attending the party tony warns that
time travel
could create several branches in time
and mordo too warned doctor strange of
this
in his solo movie doctor strange in
infinity war also said that he'd only
seen one timeline in which they won
which is why he holds up one finger in
the final battle
this also signifies that there is one
minute between him doing this
and tony carrying out the snap his
finger also shakes
as the character is still recovering
from the car crash in his solo movie
speaking of timelines you might remember
in avengers that tony told
loki there was no version in which he
would come out on top
however in this film the character
actually does
showing that tony was wrong time travel
is fascinating
and it actually seems like several
characters may have a gift with time
itself
in thor ragnarok when loki and thor are
outside shady acres the former said he
could not see into the future
as he's not a witch in end game friga
can tell that thor is from the future
because as she says she was raised by
witches
this implies that witches can tell the
future in the mcu
and i love the way it references this
line from my favorite thor movie
it's not the only touching exchange
between parent and child either
as when howard asks tony about his
father stark junior says
he did his best this is a nod to the
bath demonstration in civil war
in which tony shows that he wishes he
told his father i love your dad
and i know you did the best you could
jarvis too pops up as his butler
and if you've seen agent carter then
you'll know he was a big part in that
series
after failing to convince tony to help
them they go to bruce banner who we
learn has melded his mind with the hulk
this was actually foreshadowing in thor
ragnarok when bruce looked over the
recording from age of ultron
and we could see as the two characters
faces lined up the kids that come to
take a photo with him
are also children of the russos who too
appeared in the winter soldier
from here we watch as tony manages to
solve time travel
after inverting a mobius strip this idea
was inspired by a photo
peter parker who he saw holding up his
stock internship certificate
upside down tony even says that he got
some mild inspiration before running the
final simulation
showing that peter somewhat helped to
save the universe
now there's a ton of callbacks to their
friendship throughout the final battle
and you may remember that in spider-man
homecoming there's a hilarious scene in
which peter thought tony was going in
for a hug
tony said we're not there yet but in end
game
tony hugged peter when he saw him to
show just how much he
changed tony also hugs his dad upon
seeing him
and in iron man 2 he did tell fury that
his father never hugged him
a photo of howard is also placed in
front of the one with peter
hammering home these father and son
relationships peter and tony can be seen
holding up two fingers behind each
other's heads
and this could be interpreted as being a
peace sign in iron man
tony said that with peace he'd be out of
the job and he mocked this idea by
holding up two fingers with the soldier
in the fun b
however upon escaping the cave he held
two fingers up to the rescue chopper to
show
how much that had changed him he also
did it when exiting the senate hearing
in iron man 2
and when repairing his relationship with
cap he said
i just want peace in civil war
spider-man told tony that he'd never get
a chance to play football due to his
powers
but we do see him get the opportunity in
the final battle
in which the character literally runs
the gauntlet
you can also see peter's traditional
spider-man costume under the suit
when it becomes damaged this is because
he had it on under the iron spider armor
all the way back in infinity war and as
he died on titan and then came straight
to the final battle
he didn't have time to change tony can
also be seen cleaning up some dishes
suggesting that steve nat and scott did
stay for dinner
they just didn't talk shop morgan says i
love u3000
which tony of course says back to her in
his recording at the end
and on top of this the total run time of
the infinity saga
is three thousand minutes cut to hulk
and co trying to figure out time travel
and we actually see the big green giant
having to use a pencil to press the
buttons on the control panel
as his fingers are too big time gets
pushed through scott
and the actor that plays the teenage
version of him also played brandon in
bright burn
kill him kill him while you still can
now it is possible that if they want to
bring banner back
then they could use this machine to
reverse him to his prior form
and we do know that a younger version of
the character will be popping up in
she-hulk
so i i'm just saying fan theories abound
anyway from here they traveled to
townsburg in order to get thor
this place is actually critical to the
mcu and it was the ground in which the
asgardians fought on centuries ago
it also appeared at the beginning of
captain america as the hiding place of
the tesseract
and in ragnarok before odin died he said
to thor and loki
remember this place home here we see
that the asgardians have turned it into
a little fishing village and you can
also see a gladiator
walking around in the background as they
pull up this is actually the same one
that was in korg's uprising
all the way back in ragnarok now how
these guys survived the attack by thanos
in infinity war
is actually hinted at right at the
beginning of that movie
as we can see that the ship itself is
split in half
thanos of course had been traveling the
universe and halving the populations of
locations
and as these were the remaining
survivors of asgard he allowed half of
them to live
in thor's house we can catch a couple of
cool little easter eggs
including moss and korg mars tends to
only gather on a stone when it's been
stationary for some time
and thus this hints towards his very
very lazy lifestyle
korg is playing fortnite against noob
master 69 and we can also see that his
screen name
is ragnarok and roll thor talks about a
cable problem
and this is a reference to how josh
brolin played both cable and thanos
we can also catch your hulk and iron man
pez dispenser as thor is walking about
the property
and i really i really want to buy these
i don't i don't care if i've been
wasting my money through lockdown
now door is pretty beat up about the
whole thing with thanos
and throughout the movie we see him
putting eye drops in
however he only ever places them into
one eye
as you may remember that the character
now has a synthetic one
black widow travels to get hawkeye and
you might notice that along the skyline
in tokyo
there are several buildings that all
have their lights completely out
this hints at how low the population now
is and once more it's great attention to
detail
hawkeye and black will go on a big
journey together throughout the movie
and after the latter dies we actually
see that he takes her wristband
throughout the saga she has worn this
and
in the final battle we can see him
donning this on his left hand
you may remember that in winter soldier
nat wore an arrow necklace
so i like how there's this continued
idea of friends carrying the symbols of
each other
it isn't the only call back between
buddies either as when steve sets out on
his mission to return the stones he says
to bucky
don't do anything stupid until i get
back bucky replies how can i
you're taking all the stupid with you
this is actually a call back to captain
america the first avenger
in which the conversation was reversed
with steve delivering the opposite
dialogue to bucky
before he went off to fight in world war
ii before leaving on his mission
cap looks in the direction of where his
old version would later be sat
and he says i'll be back at the end of
the film steve and peggy finally get
that dance
and in the background we can hear the
same song from when steve found few in
his apartment all the way back in winter
soldier
the song is called it's been a long long
time which is of course a reference to
the journey that steve has been on to
finally get to his long lost love
tony calls thor lebowski because he
looks like the big lebowski
who jeff bridges aka obadiah stain
played
stark also gives rocket the nickname
ratchet and this is a nod to the furry
sony character who's great with
technology
speaking of technology the quantum realm
suits themselves
actually bring together a lot of
different technologies from the mcu
the blue visor tech is from the
guardians the pin particles help to
shrink them down
and the nanotech that creates the suits
was developed in wakanda
and adapted by tony for his suit in
infinity war hawkeye tests out time
travel
and he journeys back to his home picking
up his son's baseball glove along the
way
this is actually very important as when
his children were dusted at the
beginning of the movie
they dropped their baseball mitts so him
picking this up is symbolic of him
having another chance to get them back
after he's returned to the present we
can see that scott is carrying some
orange slices
and this is a call back to civil war in
which the character asked for some
due to being in pain because of the
airport battle the groups suit up and
head out
and when they put their hands together
it's actually meant to resemble a top
down view of the ark reactor
the first team arrive at 2012 and we
watch as tony
enters stock tower the feet on his armor
retract first
so that he can land silently in the
building we see loki impersonate captain
america which is a callback to throw the
dark world
and it also becomes the reason that cap
thinks loki is impersonating him later
during the fight older cap holds the
younger one in the headlock
and tells him about bucky which is a
call back to civil war in which
crossbones threw the character off
by also mentioning his friend on the
ground floor thor says that they're
going for lunch
which is a reference to the schwarma
scene from the post-credits scene of
avengers
we see alexander pierce from the winter
soldier and two get an amazing call back
to that movie with the elevator scene
cap realizes that he should use his
smarts instead of his fists
and drops the phrase hail hydra to get
the stuff
which is an odd to the to the rage
inducing time it turned out that he was
a hydra agent in the comics
i'll never forget now there's also a lot
of similarities in the way that the
scenes are shot
including some gun readying just in case
things go to hell
now when exiting the building tony does
a similar suit up to what he did in the
first avengers movie
however his suit quickly engages over
him instead of when he almost hit the
pavement in that movie
which shows just how far his technology
has come
he also goes out the same window that
loki threw him through in that film
and it's a nice little repeat of that
scene after that
loki gets the tesseract and goes off the
star in his own show on disney plus
the avengers are then forced to go to
the 70s namely the camp that we saw in
both captain america the first avenger
and the winter soldier upon arriving in
the decade where sean stanley
who looks exactly the same as how he did
in a picture from the era
his bumper sticker also says enough said
which is a famous line that he used to
use when writing editorials for the
comics
tony sneaks into the basement and this
is actually the place where cap and that
would find zola's consciousness stored
on data banks
at the back of the room we can actually
see zola's face on a computer screen
and not long after when steve is
sneaking around you can catch what looks
to be the doctor
tony is able to find the tesseract
because of its gamma signature
in the avengers we learn that bruce was
brought on to find the tesseract
because of the gamma that it emitted so
it's nice that it's brought up here
again
tony and his dad have a farther distant
moment and when going to shake each
other's hands
tony grabs his dad's finger to which
howard says
shake don't pull you may remember that
in infinity war
tony tried to pull the gauntlet off
thanos's hand but this didn't work
so at the end of the movie tony shakes
the stones free of thanos's gauntlet
instead of trying to pull the entire
thing throughout the saga
we've also seen as tony has refused to
be handed things
this happened at the start of iron man 2
when he was served
later when he refused to take
strawberries and at the start of the
avengers
however he happily holds flowers for his
father
because he trusts him steve catches a
glimpse of peggy carter
and we also hear her talking about
braddock aka brian braddock
aka captain britain when taking the pin
particles from hank
steve takes four in total this is two
for him
and stark to return to the present and
one for him to go to the past
and another to eventually return to the
present and as god rocket manages to get
the ether from jane foster
and he's chased through the location by
asgardian forces
they say get that rabbit which is a nod
to when thor called him one in the prior
film
one by one they get the stones back but
there's actually a clue that an
altered timeline has been created when
black widow dies we can see blood stains
beside her
and these also appeared beside gamora
when she died in infinity war
that event actually happened after what
we see in endgame
and thus the fact that widow's body
isn't there when gamora dies
shows that a branched reality was
created now the group get the stones
and return to the present in order to
carry out the snap
with them is an old version of nebula
who is still loyal to thanos
and had the avengers only paid attention
then they would have noticed this
now when removing the power stone we can
see that nebula badly damages her arm
but the one in the present is fine thus
there's clearly been a switcheroo
however the avengers are too devastated
by the death of natasha to know is this
and you may have seen several posts
stating that they represent the
kubler-ross stages of grief
thor represents denial because he
believes they can use the stones to
bring her back
hulk represents anger as he throws a
bench across the lake
steve represents bargaining as he
promised natasha that their sacrifices
would be worth it
and tony represents depression as he's
barely able to speak
hawkeye is the only one who represents
acceptance
as he says they can't go back and get
her and it can't be undone
atoni rocket and hulk place the stones
into the gauntlet
and this scene massively resembles the
one in captain america the first avenger
in which howard too moved the tesseract
about rocket jokingly says
boom but in the first avenger it did
actually explode
which is a nice little nod to that movie
thor puts himself forward to carry out
the snap
and he says that he's the strongest
avenger however
hulk ends up doing it this is something
that the pair went back and forth over
in ragnarok
and after thor failed to access the
quinjet by calling himself the strongest
avenger
hulk was able to and was greeted with
the computer calling him the moniker
or guy's wife calls him and as she was
the first person to get dusted in the
movie
i love how she's also the first person
that we know returned
thanos is pulled through the portal and
he then attacks the base
just before nebula signals for him we
can see that there's a date on the
screen which says
2988 bc this is actually the air that
the opening of thor the dark world took
place in
so it shows that the avengers had a
contingency plan in case they were
unable to get the ether
scott only manages to survive the attack
by shrinking and we can later see the
upgraded war machine armor behind him
as he looks about for survivors when war
machine is at avengers hq
he also gets out the suit by saying
canopy canopy canopy
which is code for a jacket eject eject
in the air force the trinity of the
avengers meet thanos outside
and he can be seen playing with stones
foreshadowing his goal to collect the
infinity stones once more
now the final battle has a ton of tiny
little things in it
that you may miss if you're not paying
close attention when fighting thanos
cap throws the shield and then the
hammer added which knocks thanos off
balance
and this is a call back to when the two
struck one another in avengers
cap gets the hammer and he swings it
round as a weapon whilst
using the shield to guard himself peter
parker would later do something similar
with a drone gun and signpost at the end
of far from home
showing that he learned from the
avengers that came before him
when falcon returns he says on your left
which was of course set up in the winter
soldier
and when old joe biden cap is on the
bench at the end
sam also approaches him on his left thor
uses lightning to charge your pine man's
armor
and as we discovered in avengers this
powered up the suit exponentially
the wasp exits a tiny portal and she
also calls captain america cap
which he mocked scott for doing in
ant-man in the wasp we can also see
howard the duck for a split second in
the crowd
and i know you noticed that but on my
last breakdown i thought was i was
it was so obvious i just left it out and
i got absolutely hammered for it
so i'm not doing it this time we catch
spider-man swinging on ant-man in order
to move forward
and black panther calls hawkeye clint
this is coming full circle from civil
war in which the latter tried to
introduce himself and panther said
i don't care the end of the film
culminates with tony carrying out the
snap
and killing thanos and his forces he
says i am iron man
which not only ended his first solo
movie but it was also what he said at
the end of iron man 3 to end his trilogy
it also comes at the end of his last
appearance
and i'm not i'm not crying you're crying
now not only can you hear tony's nano
machines taking the stones out of
thanos's gauntlet and putting them into
his suit
but there are also a couple of neat
little callbacks to the prior film
the first time we hear thanos talk an
infinity war he says he knows what it's
like to lose
and how it turns the legs to jelly when
dying
the first thing he does is sit down why
this scene is also perfect
is because the camera movement mimics
his victory at the end of avengers
infinity war
and it pans across exactly the same way
to show the victory and defeat in a
similar light
at tony's funeral everyone stands there
looking really sad
except for mantis who sways in a rocking
motion
this was put in place because it's
actually typical of mantids to sway
when they're stood still we also see the
kid from iron man 3 all grown up
who and i really hope the rumors are
true that he's gonna become iron lad
morgan tells happy that she wants some
cheeseburgers and this is a reference to
the first iron man
in which tony made happy get him some
after returning home from being held
hostage
we also see in peter's school that
there's a blonde head girl
with a white web pattern on her skirt
and has been theorized that this is gwen
stacy
the credits end with the clanging noise
of iron man building his suit in the
first film
and this brings everything full circle
all 22 films before this are also paid
lip service to buy stock in the
beginning of endgame
who says they've been adrift for 21 days
no
22. anyway that's our entire list
and i just want to give a huge thank you
to you for staying until the end
a ton of work went into this video so if
you enjoyed it then please please drop a
thumbs up
i know you've probably seen some of
these easter eggs in not only my videos
but also ones by new rock stars canadian
lad
beyond epic and screen crush so also
huge shout outs to them as well
these easter eggs have been floating
around in my head for for the best part
of a year now
and it's always difficult to remember
exactly where they first came from
and i have nothing but appreciation for
my fellow easter egg hunters out there
so yeah definitely check out those
channels as well now the next saga we're
going to be tackling is the dark knight
trilogy
but i will of course be popping back to
cover the marvel movies that i haven't
so far
such as doctor strange and ant-man so
definitely stick around for them
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come check this on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
now not only can you hear tony's nano
machines taking the stones off thanos's
gauntlet and putting them into his suit
but there are also a couple of neat
little call backs to the prior film